♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Nina] I'm delighted to be here. Even 20
years ago, if someone asked you to imagine
or to think about human evolution, you
would think fossils. Maybe you would think
about bones. Rarely would you ever think
about skin. So, it's no wonder that in
this grand question that Ajit posed; that
skin received very short shrift. Skin,
after all, is rarely preserved for more
than a few thousand years, so we have no
or very little physical evidence of it.
So, because anthropologists and human
biologists like hard evidence, physical
hard evidence that they can examine, skin
for years, if it was studied at all, was
studied from the perspective of
comparative anatomy, inlcuding histology,
some physiology, some, a little bit, of
genetics.
But things have changed dramatically, and
in the last 20 years, skin has been
studied from a variety of perspectives.
And in fact, the whole field of human
evolution is now studied from a variety of
perspectives. Not just fossil evidence and
a little bit of comparative anatomy, but
comparative and functional genomics,
evolutionary developmental biology,
studies of the micro-biome and a myriad
of others. We can bring so many lines of
evidence to bear and that's what we're
going to do today. What was almost a
complete mystery 20 or 25 years ago, or
something about which we knew very little,
we now know much more about.
Today, we have assembled a series of
scholars and many of them don't even
self-identify as evolutionary biologists,
but they're doing work that is highly
pertinent to human evolutionary biology.
And we've brought them together because
they're doing exciting and important work
related to this largest organ of our
bodies that is more different than any
other organ system that we have, compared
to that of our closest relatives,
chimpanzees. What an exciting day. We're
going to be sharing in the work of some of
human evolution's best detectives. So,
with that brief and I hope intriguing
introduction, I want to introduce our
first speaker, Richard Gallo, who will
start us off in this marvelous journey of
discovery into the unique aspects of human
skin.
I'm tremendously grateful to Ajit Varki,
Pascal Gagneux and all of the CARTA
organizers and sponsors for making this,
which I hope will be a wonderful event,
possible.
♪ [music] ♪